[Music]
hello everyone so that was music from
rick viado's composition in seven modes
of the harmonic major scale i've been a
huge fan of his music and this piece in
particular caught my attention so i've
been working on it and i just wanted to
show you some of the ways i worked out
the fingerings and the hand distribution
in this piece because i it was a really
neat challenge for me and i thought
there were some some great points on
fingering in general that i could show
you all so the basic principle is to
keep the left hand rather stationary
and have the right hand do most of the
work
so i do this because it's both easier to
play and also more rhythmic
this is what i thought i was going to do
at first left hand
right hand and then left hand
right hand
so i was using these
four notes as a position for my left
hand but i quickly realized that
at a fast tempo it's not really reliable
because this is a stretch
so from five to three
stretching a fifth is kind of
[Music]
uncomfortable so by distributing the
hands in this way where
i'm choosing a more comfortable position
for my left hand
and using my right hand for all the
other notes
it's a lot more reliable and it's a lot
more rhythmic it's really interesting
and complex because the turns and the
leaps and the intervals between the
notes create a different dimension of
rhythm
and i want to try to bring that out with
this hand distribution as well
so since i'm going to be playing this at
a very fast tempo hopefully i want to
avoid large leaves with just one hand so
in this case
i'll distribute it so that my left hand
is only stretching
from c to a flat
so here i had a few different options in
mine i tried
switching over so i could play all of
this with my left hand
but i felt that
that's not reliable at a fast tempo
so i decided
this is comfortable
and beyond that i'm going to use my
right hand
but since here
that's the first time there are two
notes playing at one time
[Music]
so i want to position myself so that
it's easy to do that
the solution that i found
is to play that with the left hand
right hand
and then just play the a flat with the
left hand
that way
my pinky will already be on the c
and i can play that octave comfortably
if i used my fourth finger for the c
my first and fifth finger are already at
the fifth
and since the left hand is not playing
when i'm playing the fifth
i have time to switch over to new
position
and i chose to use a thumb because i
look at the next set of notes as this
position
and because the a flat is included in
this position
i'll use it with my second finger and
then change over to the next position
which is g f d
with this chord
i cannot reach
these notes with one hand it's
impossible for me it would be great if i
could because then i can just play
that augmented triad with my left hand
but since i can't i'm going to add the c
with my left hand
and that's relatively okay because i'm
just shifting over one note
from here
to here
what i'm doing with my right hand is
that i'm playing the fifth with one and
five
then f and e with two one
that's comfortable
and when i play the e with my thumb the
f and g are already with fingers two and
three so i'm going to go ahead and use
that
and then here i switch my position to
this chord
and i like that because when i'm using
my thumb on a black key
there's space around it
so i feel rather secure
using that as an anchor
and then i'll be using my thumb to play
f and g together
[Music]
otherwise
it would be uncomfortable to go
[Music]
like that so to recap let's see
so looking at the right hand here
i'm always trying to find a fingering
that suits the natural position of the
hand
so if i have fingers naturally over
notes that i'm going to be playing
like here
i'm not going to change positions
[Music]
i'll wait until i can play all the notes
and then i'll change
here thumb
to index finger
these are comfortable
and then i'll change again
also i want to check this at a faster
tempo
okay that's okay
i'll switch over to the thumb on the d
this one
because i can get more notes after that
if i choose to play the d with the
second finger
that limits what i can do afterwards so
even though it's in line with what i
said before but i'll play something
with the finger that's already there
[Music]
i'll change my mind here because if i
were to do that
[Music]
i'm limited for the next notes
so you kind of have to see the context
of of which notes you're looking at
so i'll use the thumb here
and then the rest is straightforward
so basically fingering makes a huge
difference in how you play peace
and it's a fluid thing it can constantly
change even with this
in the first two days i must have
changed the fingerings
in different parts at least three or
four times
and that final take
it must have taken me about two dozen
times to get it right so i have a long
way to go so i expect it to keep
changing but in general the more
analytical you are about which
fingerings to use the more reliable they
will be
throughout the course of you playing the
piece so that's all
thanks very much for watching and i'll
see you next time
[Music]
you